INTRO:
You know how gas prices have come down substantially
over the past few months forom over $5 per
gallon to just under $4 per gallon?
Now of course, $4 per gallon is still significantly
higher than where we were just a year ago,
but it is nonetheless still progress from
$5 per gallon.
This has caused many to assume that supply
chain issues have been resolving and that
inflation has been cooling down and so on.
And while these factors definitely do play
a role, one of the most blatant reasons for
the recent decrease is oil stimulus from the
US.
You see, the US department of Energy likes
to keep a back up oil reserve called the US
Strategic Petroleum Reserve.
This reserve is meant for serious emergencies
like the US getting into a war or the Middle
East staging a strike.
But, since March of this year, the US has
been using these reserves to alleviate gas
prices.
Whether this is a justifiable reason is debateable,
but one thing that’s for sure is that the
US has been depleting these reserves fast.
I could go through the specific numbers and
stuff, but I think just looking at this chart
will tell you everything you need to know.
So how much longer do we have until the US
depletes their backup reserves.
THE COUNTDOWN:
To estimate how much time we have left, the
easiest thing to do would be to calculate
the average rate of decline and use that to
project into the future.
If you zoom into the chart, you’ll see that
the cliff dive really started in April of
2022 when the reserves stood at 568 million
barrels of oil.
If we scroll over to October, however, the
reserves are estimated to stand at just 359
million barrels.
That right there is not only a 40 year low
in terms of reserves but also a record pace
of decline.
During this 6 month period, the US would’ve
have used up 209 million barrels of reserve
oil.
That translates to an average of about 35
million barrels per month.
At that rate, the reserves would only last
for another 10 months taking us to about August
of next year.
But, if we look closer at the data, we’ll
see that we don’t have nearly that much
time.
Here’s the thing, not all crude oil is created
equal and the US doesn’t just store one
type of crude oil.
They actually store two types called medium-sour
and light-sweet.
To the naked eye, both of these would look
the same as the differences are mainly internal.
Medium-sour oil has a higher density and a
higher sulfur content which what the world
has become accustomed to.
This is the type of oil that is pumped out
of Russia, Venezuela and much of the Middle
East.
And this is the type of oil that the US refiners
are used to.
And given that refiners are currently the
biggest bottleneck in the oil market, the
US has leaned into their needs.
In other words, the vast majority of oil the
US has been unloading as in 85% is medium
sour crude oil.
This means that out of the 35 million barrels
that they were offloading every month, roughly
30 million barrels were sour and 5 million
were sweet.
This wouldn’t be that big of a problem if
medium sour accounted for 85% of their reserves,
but it doesn’t.
According to government’s website, 40% of
their reserves were sweet and 60% were sour
as of the beginning of 2022.
If we assume that this ratio was more or less
maintained until we saw the cliff dive in
April, we started with roughly 340 million
barrels of sour oil and 227 million barrels
of sweet oil.
At a rate of 30 million barrels of sour oil
and 5 million barrels of sweet oil every month,
we’ll be left with approximately 160 million
barrels of sour oil and 197 million barrels
of sweet oil by October.
If we don’t change up our rate of consumption
or ratio of consumption, the sour oil reserves
will be gone by March.
As for the sweet oil reserves, we’ll still
have plenty of that, but that probably wouldn’t
be all that helpful.
Here’s the thing, when you have a refining
bottle neck with sweet oil, pumping up the
supply won’t actually lead to more final
output.
Also, it’s unlikely that refiners will be
willing to expand their light sweet operations
all that much when this is just a temporary
influx of sweet oil.
So, the countdown has already started, at
it’s just a matter of months until the US
will have to pull the plug.
RUGPULL:
Now, you might be thinking that this was a
nice thing for the government to do.
They finally stepped up and took action against
oil prices that were spiraling out of control.
While that could definitely be the case, it’s
not that likely.
You see, the US never taps into this oil reserve.
Looking at this graph, you can see that the
reserves are always stagnating or going up.
This is literally the first the time the US
has been depleting SPR reserves since it was
created way back in 1975.
They didn’t even deplete the reserves in
2008 when the US saw a massive recession and
oil prices hit over $180 per barrel.
So, clearly, they’re more desperate than
ever before.
And why are they more desperate than ever
before, well it’s because inflation is way
out of control and its making the incumbent
politicians look incompetent right before
the mid term elections.
And that right there is the key to everything
they’ve been doing.
Obviously, there’s nothing the politicians
can do to bring inflation down to 3% or solve
the supply shortage within the next two months.
But, something they can do is deplete the
emergency oil reserves to create the impression
that inflation is coming down.
Here’s the thing, the average person doesn’t
actually follow CPI readings on a monthly
basis.
Their gauge of inflation is simply based on
how much their daily and monthly expenses
are.
If they suddenly go to the pump one day and
their bill is $10 lower than usual, they’re
gonna assume that inflation is getting better.
It’s not just the pump that they’ll see
this difference either.
When you bring down oil prices, you bring
down prices across the board because almost
all everyday goods rely on transportation.
Take milk prices for example.
Milk is still super expensive on a historical
basis, but prices have stopped going up since
May.
We don’t know how much of this is actually
due to oil prices coming down, but one thing’s
for sure, they’re definitely trying.
The only problem though is that all the signs
point to them stopping trying right after
the election is over.
Take the oil depletion for example.
If the rate of depletion was 15 or 20 million
barrels of oil per month, we could come to
the conclusion that maybe its more of a long
term plan.
This rate would actually be sustainable for
a few years which might be enough time for
oil prices to naturally cool down.
But, with a depletion rate of 35 million barrels
per month and sour oil reserves being projected
to run out by Q2 of next year, it’s hard
to believe that this is anything but a short
term political play.
It seems like they wanted to bring down oil
prices as much as much as possible before
the election, but after the election, it doesn’t
seem like they care all that much.
Even if they did care, it’s not like they
could do anything about it given that the
oil reserves would already be nearly depleted.
So, in my opinion, I think it’s highly likely
that they rugpull us shortly after the election,
but I’ll let you be the judge of that.
AFTERMATH:
Whether this is all just one big political
move or not, in the end, it doesn’t really
matter.
Either way, we end up in the same destination
which is depleted emergency oil reserves.
So, what happens next?
Well, fortunately for us, the US department
of Treasury has done some studies regarding
how the emergency reserves are affecting gas
prices.
To accomplish this, they looked at data regarding
the stock of oil or the supply and the flow
of oil.
Now of course, no model is perfect and that
applies to the US Treasury as well.
For example, in their calculations, they assumed
that there is zero elasticity on the supply
side.
Similarly, they also assumed that logistical
and technical issues can be ignored.
Given how bad the supply chain has been over
the past 2 years, these assumptions are obviously
not super realistic, but it’s the best that
we’ve got.
According to the study, the release of American
oil reserves has resulted in a price reduction
of 33 cents per gallon.
Something that we should note is that it wasn’t
just the US that was depleting their oil reserves
either.
When President Biden announced his plan to
leverage American reserves, he also got partners
in the IEA or the International Energy Agency
to play along.
Together, it’s estimated that they’ve
brought down oil prices by approximately 0.38
center per gallon.
So, simple logic tells us that when these
organizations stop injecting oil in the system,
gas prices should go up by 38 cents, but it’s
obviously not that simple.
If oil prices naturally cool down by this
point, then maybe we can see oil prices continue
to trend down even after these guys withdraw
their support.
This would be the most ideal situation, and
hopefully, it’s what happens.
If oil prices are still at relatively high
levels, however, we could easily see oil prices
spike by much more than 38 cents because we
would no longer have a safety net.
Oil suppliers will be well aware that the
US can’t pull off this stunt again, so they
might have even more pricing power than they
had before this fiasco.
The country that America would really have
to worry about is not Saudi Arabia or some
other Middle Eastern country, they would actually
have to worry about Canada.
Most people don’t know this, but Canada
is actually America’s number 1 sources of
imported oil.
Literally 62% of US crude oil imports comes
from Canada, so they have quite a bit of power.
Fortunately, the US and Canada are pretty
good allies, so it’s extremely unlikely
that Canada would do anything to destroy America.
For example, they’re not gonna stop oil
exports altogether and watch as gas prices
shoot up to $30 per gallon in America.
But, just because they wont do something so
drastic doesn’t mean that they’ll be gracious
with pricing because America has never been
gracious with pricing when it comes to Canadian
oil.
You see, Canada actually has the third largest
oil reserves in the entire world.
But, they’ve never really been able to leverage
this to become a global player.
If you’re interested in why, I have a full
video about Canada’s oil situation.
But, long story short, Canada has been forced
into a situation where 99% of their oil ends
up in the North American market or basically
just America.
And this has given the US the opportunity
to basically blackmail Canada into giving
them cheap oil.
The argument from the US is usually, we have
these massive reserves as well sources from
Russia and the Middle East.
So, we don’t need you, you need us, so if
you want us to buy your oil, give us a discount.
And that’s exactly what Canada’s been
doing with the average discount on Canadian
oil being $20 per barrel.
But, now the table have turned.
The emergency reserves are rapidly depleting
and Russia is out of the equation, so Canada
has the upper hand.
And honestly, after getting taken advantage
of for so many decades, I think it’s only
fair that Canada gets to turn the script on
the US, but let’s just say, it wont be very
fun for our pocket books.
GAS PRICES:
In the end, if you’ve been wondering why
gas prices have been plummeting over the past
few months, it’s not because inflation is
coming down.
It’s actually because the government has
essentially been handing out gas stimulus
from their emergency reserves.
At the current rate, however, they wont be
able to sustain this stimulus for much longer,
but honestly, that seems to have been their
plan all along.
Cool down gas prices before the election as
much as possible and we’ll worry about the
rest later.
In the medium term, this may end up giving
Canada more pricing power than ever, allowing
them to finally have some time in the spotlight
at the expense of everyday Americans.
Again, I wouldn’t blame Canada for this,
but rather American politicians for putting
America in such a situation.
But, that’s just what I think.
Do you think it was justified to leverage
the emergency oil reserves?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish politicians
didn’t just care about elections.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.